I [music] could see that I I understand this is what does any
of this matter because we're not >> I tried to tell you
how you made me feel >> and you said that it it it wasn't
that deep or like oh you're crashing out for no reason >> because
you would tell me that like you can't breathe without me AND
[__] >> I NEVER
WA OKAY, NOW you're like
here we go. title switch up and we're on to it. Let's go. Let's
go.
>> Reinforces my
>> So MC wanted to go out and do and nobody else wanted
to go out and do. So MK ended up going out or sorry Murk ended
up getting kind of and started to leak and try to start.
All right. Is MK living in that house now? Uh I don't know. I
don't think so. I think she's just in Austin.
I don't think she's living in the house.
>> you see your nail pattern. You are the last person to
be talking about anyone's >> Look at her eyes twitching.
You know I got through a little bit.
>> If anything, it reinforces my
>> It tells me I'm doing a good job.
>> Oh. Um, I should get the names. I should refigure out
the names for myself here real quick. Um, who's Darius's new
girl? Cuz she just walked by, right?
I don't >> I forget. Somebody Somebody get me the name
of Darius's new girl. The girl he's working with now. >> He's
like doing new He's doing some
Dayquil. Yeah, Dayquil. Yeah, >> he's been hanging out
with like this other girl. It's not the Asian girl from
No, no, no. Not Kerbene. No, the Dayquil
>> Cuz Darius is basically like hooking up with this other
girl. And now I think Murk's obviously gonna be jealous of that.
She's gonna be jealous of this basically always, right? Isn't
it Prawn's girl?
He stole her from Prawn. Yeah, I thought he definitely stole
her from correctly on several occasions being anorex.
>> [__] I never said that. >> Really?
Whenever um I brought up the fact uh about Adri being on aderall.
>> She's not on aderall. She literally called you on stream
one time saying that her mother got her brother's ado and gave
it to her. She said,
>> "Okay." Uh, so Darius walks outside. That's one of those
things where it's like, "Hey, don't leak random that you learned
from me from other people."
Hey, that thing that happened like while she called me in private
off stream. Maybe don't drop that on stream. Maybe don't drop
that on Hey, just quick quick thought. Don't drop random information
about other streamers and my roommate Paul Ru streaming. Don't
do that. >> First off, that's insane. But she that probably
that probably gonna happen.
>> that doesn't mean she's on aderall though. Being on
adal means you're regularly taking making it. She did a like
once or twice. >> Okay, so why would I make up this narrative
that she stole it from her brother who's on? >> I don't
think that you made it up. >> She called you. You were
at your desk one time and she called you on stream. So, just
for context here, Merk, this is like I think Merk's, you know,
she's been escalating for a while now cuz she wanted to go out
and do other and everybody else wanted to hang out there. And
so, she's probably feeling like not seen, not heard, feeling
a little agitated. So, she starts trying to start with people.
And this is the one where I think Darius finally bites and then
they actually get into an argument. >> That could have
definitely happened. That could I'm not saying that didn't happen.
But you're saying, "Oh, you're on." Okay. If I said,
>> "Wait, if you did weed like once or twice, I'm like,
"Oh, you're just like a pthead." Oh, dude. Mark's a pthead. You're
saying she's on Adderall. She's not on Adderall.
>> That's like someone else's script. It's using
script. So that technically is >> Why is over there?
>> So she's because if she was critically,
>> you can still get a D. It's Texas. Texas is incredibly
hard to get a DIAGNOSIS FOR ADHD. >> WHOA. THAT'S
>> he's so close. >> No, but I understand why people
would look for underhanded methods in this
>> I think >> I probably did say that to bother you.
>> I would.
>> Wait, so I think Murk's whole argument here, she's doing
this to prove that Darius called her an anorexic. >> Deny
I said that. But why are you making it sound like he's just he
looks at the dog, sees the dog like trying to grab something
off the counter and then goes back to the argument. doesn't even
say Jimbo stop. >> You were just like, I just made a little
point and then you got no mad at me. >> I have two drinks
tonight. I'm only on my second drink and I feel like you're being
harassed by >> I've been
legacy coping with his alcoholism in the background. Guys, I'M
ONLY ON MY SECOND DRINK TONIGHT. I'm only my second drink tonight,
guys. I don't even find Mark attractive yet. I'm not even drunk.
I'm only on my second >> drinking this entire time. What
is up with your attitude? Damn, dude.
I've seen you guys drink beers. I've seen you guys drink liquor.
>> What is like listen? >> I get it. We're not the
greatest friends right now, but like >> at least
four drinks each.
>> There's obviously something in the air.
>> It may not be.
>> Could be my stench. And maybe
>> I'm going to be watching all of you guys. Maybe
>> uh the audio is better from her angle. Okay, give me
a second.
>> Exactly where you said it. >> You know, I don't
need to regular
>> She said her mother. Okay. So, why would I make up this
narrative that she stole it from her brother? >> I don't
think that you made it. >> She called you. You were at
your desk one time and she called you and it was on stream. It
was on. >> Here you go. This is how this is how you know
it's like okay is Murk is explicitly saying yeah this happened
in private you had no way of knowing about it and or sorry you
nobody else had any way of knowing about it I'm I'm just taking
private information making it public about your
literally said I'm an anorexic who abuses OP you said I abuse
you like once or twice >> oh my god I'm not [__]
a pthead you're saying she's on adal is that
There you go. >> Well, abusing someone else's script. It's
using it when it's not your script. So, that technically isn't
using
>> because if she was clinically ADHD, she would have had
a diagnosis. >> You can still get a Texas. Texas is incredibly
hard to get a diagnosis for
>> That's not my
>> But you still said I was anorexic.
She's joining the cast of Wicked.
>> I don't know.
I I feel like
>> I'm probably getting a [__] for this. I
think Murk I think she looks best when she's like this weight
which is up cuz she's clearly underweight. Okay.
>> I don't I don't know how else to say that. I'm sorry.
>> I can pull up your logs right now. >> I probably
did say that bother
making it sound like it's like >> I just made a little
point and then you got no matter
tonight. I'm only on my >> break and are we drinking or
what? Last fight ever. >> She did. She did kind of win.
Okay. But Darius, now that she's won,
Darius is obviously going to get about it, right? Cuz she just
leaked some and she's like, "Okay, well, obviously I'm correct."
She is correct, by the way. She's saying that
you said that I am an anorexic [__] And he's like,
"I've never said that. When did I say that?" Well, when I She
gives a time and he goes, "No, that didn't happen." And she's
like, "Here's something I leaked to prove it happened." And then
he goes, "Well, she doesn't abuse Adriana doesn't abuse Aderall."
And then Merk's like, "Well, you said I abused his Empic for
the exact same reason." Like, okay. Um, and Darius had no response.
Okay. So, MK did win. Uh, she looks super unhealthy during that
Darius car trunk stream from like a week ago. Looks better now.
Yeah, I've seen someone somewhere she doesn't look great. Um,
being the skinny. She looks good now. Drinking this entire time.
What is up with your attitude,
dude? Now she's like, "Let's get back to >> I've seen you
guys drink beers. I've seen you guys drink liquor.
>> Like, listen, >> I get it. We're not the greatest
friends right now, but like >> you at least have four drinks
each.
>> There's obviously something in the air.
>> It may not be your stench. >> It could be my showering.
>> And maybe
you stink.
Maybe my stench isn't so much for you.
>> Stench has a negative conotation in
>> this is uh this is this is Darius's Riz. Okay, this
is how he works. This is how it this is how he works. This is
how it works. All right,
listen.
It's gross, but I don't know. It's like um it's like negging.
Okay, it shouldn't work, but it does. There are people who are
damaged. There are people who it works on and it it just it just
works. Okay, don't question it. Look at the results. Don't question
the method. >> It is bad. >> You stink.
>> Okay, but maybe we don't need to like >> maybe
you like the opportunity have to
sell your >> the smell.
>> It's pherommones. Maybe it's >> Were you guys
were you guys on list? >> I don't know. >> I can't
tell you. smells.
>> Well, all I'm saying is is that we don't need to be
so hostile.
>> I'm not here to attack you.
>> It was very funny.
>> Can I get a shot, please?
>> Okay, just so you guys know, we're building up. Okay,
we're building up. This is the start. This is obviously not the
peak content, just so you know. This is us understanding context
early in the night. All right. Why they were fighting earlier
on,
why why it progresses in the way it does. Okay. This is important
>> Dude, this is not music. What the [__] >> We're
playing
music anymore. >> Who decided to put music on?
>> Oh, no. I know. >> Wait. Wait, I No, wait. >> Cowboy
Heritage should have got out my
>> Is that
you guys playing a video game?
>> It's too hard. >> What is What is >> Okay,
great. It is too hard. Awesome.
>> Okay, no problem. >> We're waiting. We're waiting
on something specific. Okay.
>> Throw on a nuke video.
>> That's crazy.
sort of >> Darius finally hit rock bottom sha with merc.
You got stuck to the chair.
>> Keep going in the [__] portal.
>> I don't want to [__] try. >> I want
to listen to the music, man.
>> Sex with JC.
That's crazy.
>> Darius can't get the stream. >> Where's the part?
was bragging about how much money she makes. I think it's a little
ironic.
>> Did she say that? >> Yeah. Remember you were defending
me on the dating show where you >> she smashed >> I
dude all it took for all of these people to switch from like
blue pill and and like believing women are like human beings
with agency
was Destiny getting a lawsuit against him and now they're all
just talking about gold digging. Like how do you how do you fight
that as a DJ you have to accept that it's a total Myron Gaines
victory,
right? They just all believe exactly what Myron Gaines believes
now like he actually everybody. He he won completely like everybody
in DGG just totally operates the way he does towards women now.
That's like how they talk about it. I
I I don't know if they ever grapple with that. It's just very
strange to me. >> She gets luck right now >> being
a streamer have anything to do with you?
She talked about not having money, but then the entire stream
she was with you, she brags about how much money she made. >> Maybe
she got a raise by then.
>> You're talking about Kirby now. >> Basically,
the thing she doesn't apparently like me for, she's now >> doing
more than I do >> cuz have you ever known me to brag about
how much money I make. >> Maybe she's
>> changing your mind.
not. Yeah, [sighs] >> we should do a monkey segment. >> Maybe.
I'm pretty >> cook off. But I feel like everyone in the
room only knows how to cook ramen. And when I say cook, I meant
microwave. >> She's got no money now. She's paying dairy
ass legal fees. No joke. >> Okay, so Murk Murk references
uh Kerbine here. I think this is about where it ends. I'm guessing
this is important context for later. We need to know that they
were fighting.
apparently her and Keri know each other. They were on a show
with Princess few months ago. Love or the bag. Princess was running
the show. Is this Prawn
>> Oh Jesus. That's Ruby. I'm so sorry. >> I just
want
cardio. >> I just immediately like something about the
pause frame. I was like, "Oh. Oh, that looks like Prawn. I It
was a joke. It was a joke. It was a joke. It's It's
>> I'm sorry.
>> Ry scrubbed that from the VOD.
>> Looks nothing like Princess.
They were sitting a certain way. I was just like, "Oh, it's a
pale person with like a an ovalshaped head." Okay. >> A
lot of endurance trading. >> This is the source of Mercur's
anger at Kerbade. Okay.
>> Um her her life question mark.
>> What's like what's what she's doing with her life that's
really stupid to you >> Uh to me personally, I think uh
>> yeah. Uh there there I mean there's a lot. Um
>> uh Mugwamps, if you're behind, this is Kerbopene. This
is This person's obsessed with Darius now. This was 3 months
ago. They're like totally obsessed with Darius now. We're like
giving him money. We're trying to take a dog that Darius had
to sell it to her parents so Darius could make money to pay his
lawyers, right? >> I think it's it's stupid that she wants
to commit so hard to like streaming in general when it's like
she's like, "Oh my god." Uh like I can The whole $150 thing really
uh peeped me off to me
>> Are they dating? No. Darius is farming people like this
who are obsessed with him and then they he basically goes and
tries to hit on other women to make them crash out like a persistent
pattern of he will give them attention and then he goes and tries
to give other people attention so he will make them crash the
out
so he'll farm people like Kerbine or Murka or whoever and then
he will intentionally as they become like more obsessed with
him more into him he will totally ignore them and give attention
purely to other people to make them crash out. >> Yeah,
I don't have her money too so I don't know why she keeps doing
that. 150 really peeved me off.
>> But what what was the specifics of that that peeved
you off? You think she's warranted toward her money? >> Uh
150 peed me off because um
I can stream for like a second and then
>> I struggle with that in I don't know. >> Oh, what
are you saying right now? >> You're not making sense of
money. >> I I I struggle.
So apparently MC, you know, either viewcount mogged or money
mogged Kerbine. Kerbene's like, "Oh, I hate that she's talking
about how much money she makes." And then Kerbine started talking
about how much money she makes. And that's the point MC was making.
Holy [__] Can any of these people make a point in
a straight line?
My god.
Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. And then we are going. So basically
eventually everybody gets convinced to go out for the night and
Jerry and Mark are in a car together. Okay. Darius and Merk are
in a car together. This is their cameras combined. So, give me
a second here. I'll turn it up. I'll be right back after this.
I'm going to hit play, but we're we're going to actually start
getting into the fight. >> You guys are assisting in the
aura being
>> Murk is definitely having negative war right now. >> Oh,
negative.
>> We just wanted arm katon and white katon. Man, >> I
not all your >> We can We can fight if you want to >> We
don't have to fight, but you know what you're doing. I know.
I have >> I said I said that you could play a drinking
game. >> I don't want to just sit there and do
>> Let us You were negative before that. >> You think
that cat just wants to sit here and be a [__] all
night? >> Yes, actually. >> Stay home. Stay home.
>> Okay. Well, I invite you out quick cuz it was a Friendsgiving.
We're getting food and stuff and chatting and then you missed
the >> Well, then you should have communicated >> I
did. I said that earlier. >> No, you said come get food.
>> I said come. Yeah, cuz after that >> I don't want
to eat. So, if I didn't want to eat or I wanted to eat food bad
enough, I could have just had the food that I had at my house.
We're both streaming. We are streamers. Surprise. Want to do
something besides sitting there and just [__] not
talk like you should have communicated that. >> Oh my god.
So, I'm in the fault because I want to do something for you.
I literally I literally cuz I told you >> because I want
to make content. Gotcha. I literally said Okay, buddy. I literally
said no, you didn't say anything. You said we're having Friendsgiving.
There's food. Come over. That's all you said. We can look at
the
>> So Darius invited her over for food to hang out for
a little bit and then she's getting mad that they don't want
to go and do stuff. Darius wants to sit there and he wants to
chill. >> I don't know why Mark's freaking out about it.
>> But isn't that literally what we're >> Okay, so
then let's just sit and talk >> and eat food. Yeah, >> because
I Everyone was already done >> Yeah, all their bellies
were full. >> Everyone Okay, so how are you blaming >> Because
I told you like 3 hours ago >> it takes I live 45 minutes
away. What are you talking about? 4 hours ago. I thought I was
at the gym.
>> This is This is a what do you call it? This is a
Oh, yeah. Thank you, Ry these up. It's actually very nice to
have both cameras up. Okay, now the misalignment going on here.
Mark clearly did not come over to just hang out right. She got
dressed up. She put put on makeup. She got all like dalled up
and came over and was probably Yeah. expecting like, "Oh, we're
going to hang out. We're going to do stuff the whole night."
And Darius is like, "Yeah, why don't you drive like 45 minutes
just to have dinner and then leave or just hang out? We're we're
all home bodies tonight." And she So Darius is sitting here in
a hoodie. He's like ready to chill.
She seems to have bullied them into going out, though. So W MK,
she >> No, I can literally look at the timestamp of your
chat. So you're mad because I had to get showered. >> I'm
not mad at all >> and I was sending emails. So how is it
my fault? Because nobody else was eating. What? >> Nobody's
saying it's your fault. I'm just saying that you're like >> because
I want to do content because I want to do something fun. >> We
could just hang out and [__] >> Hang out. Okay.
Hang out. I And what did I say? Let's play some drinking games.
Nobody was playing music. There was no music playing. Sit in
the quiet and just >> Yeah, that's fault. I'm never letting
out of control anything ever again.
>> Darius is very avoidant. He doesn't want to fight. He
just wants to
Listen, they're going out. Okay, you're going out. Just be happy.
And I'm sorry. If I wanted to hang out, it wouldn't be on stream
to sit there and just talk and do what I do regularly. We could
have got on a Discord call and talked.
>> You can make that argument up. >> these are all
true things, but also
Murk could easily just hammer out her plans. Just hammer out
your plans, bro. Just be like, "Hey, I'm going to want to go
out. Hey, are we going to go out?" Right? Hey, I'm going to go
out and we're going to we're going to like have party night.
We're going to go do content. Let's go.
Right. But instead, she like just showed up wanting all of those
things, not not expressing any of those expectations. >> Okay,
dude. Okay, then whatever. Like, I don't know how you're literally
blaming me for this. >> This is just true, Dung Devil.
Yes, >> because I want to die. I I said so much for that.
>> You have a negative attitude. >> A negative attitude
because I want to do
>> Are we going to the bridge or not? >> I don't
know. Let me get them over the
>> Yeah, it's my fault.
Okay. So, this guy says, "You're a content black hole." So, you
would have just wanted me to sit there and just us sit there
awkwardly. Is that what you're >> Wait, why? How is Murk
a content? Murka is not a content black hole. Wait, what?
>> I What?
She She is the content. She is the thing that's making content
happen right now. People get so mad when there's somebody who
like makes the content that just like the content is like hating
the woman. But you if you don't acknowledge or understand that
the woman is making the content happen, you're like I don't know.
You're never going to make it. You're just not going to make
it. You're like, you've been filtered.
The the un the completely unbridled
vitriel that people toss at Merc or Lav or some of these other
people who just make the content happen makes no sense to me.
You'd just be you'd just be watching this guy play League of
Legends if these women didn't exist. Okay, that would be the
content.
You're saying, >> "Well, things would happen naturally
if we're having positive conversation when I'm just like talking."
>> Nobody's talking. They were playing a video game. >> So,
you're coming for me? No, don't gaslight me. >> Do not
gaslight me. They were sitting there playing a [__]
video game. >> People would talk. >> They literally
They literally were playing a video game, sitting on the
>> Yes or no? Yes or no? Were they sitting there on the
couch playing a video game? >> I like the pisco strategy.
Okay. >> Yes or no? >> Thank you. >> Yes or
no? >> There's a buzzing right there. Yeah. >> I'm
definitely gaslighting you. >> You could just put it in
the EMF where your coochie is. >> I don't I don't care.
>> Is it going off? >> No, it's not on. >> Take
accountability. What do I need to take accountability for?
>> You've been a lot more angry lately, >> No, like
I said, I clocked the tea. You're mad that I'm not fawning over
you and you can't farm me anymore. That is the truth. >> I'm
farming you regardless. So, I don't >> It's okay. Oh, wait.
I was gonna Oh, Darius is doing my job. Yeah, >> you can't
farm me anymore. Here you are with all of these expectations.
You showed up. You didn't get paid, right?
He's He's sitting here chilling and you're getting more and more
angry. He's not doing any work, but all the viewers are going
to go to him.
>> They all see what's happening. How does she not see
it? >> You're farming me. Okay, so farming me, not wanting
to deal with you anymore in a romantic act aspect. >> So,
there's a form both. >> So, then that's what we were doing.
So, why do you care? We were doing that >> because I felt
>> and you were over there saying you were over there saying
you were tired.
>> You were saying you were tired >> cuz I didn't
want to sit here and fight with you. I don't want to fight. >> We
weren't fighting. You said you were farming me, right? >> Cuz
I didn't want to sit here and fight with you. >> We weren't
fighting.
>> Oh, we weren't fighting. Darius
>> Darius is in it right now. Okay. Darius is He's in it
right now. >> He is so in it. It's uh
Bro, she literally yells it at him. We're not fighting. We're
not fighting. She's like, "Oh, it's one of those nights. We're
farming nights." >> So, either way, you're farming. So,
what does it matter? >> I don't know what else to do cuz
every time I talk to you, it's just like >> you don't know
what else to do. >> You're like mad at me or something.
>> So, let's do something productive. Like, what? Just
give him what he wants. What does he want? >> You want
to know what daddy wants? >> Do not speak to me like that.
>> Let's go to the bridge, guys.
And I'm like, "Okay, well, let's do what chat wants. We can't
just sit there and do nothing. >> You're just kind of like
like angry
>> because we're not doing anything. We're >> Is
he coming?" >> So, Darius has noticed a little thing here.
Okay. Darius has noticed a little thing and that is he's noticed.
He's perceptive. He's not as dumb as some people think. Okay.
He's noticed. This is my music, by the way. Um,
he has noticed that as he becomes like more lethargic, as he
continues to be like total like barely responding, being very
short, Murk is getting more and more agitated. He now can see
as he puts less effort into the conversation.
>> Oh, wait, hold on. Is the mic not
>> Yeah. As he puts less work in the conversation, she
becomes more agitated. He He's just realized that he can he can
play the best card anybody can ever play. He can do nothing and
win. Okay. That's the plan for Darius here. Do nothing and then
win. Do nothing and win. It's all a merc to not get totally triggered
by him doing nothing. That's all she's got to do. Maintain maintain
your discipline while he just pretends that he doesn't care about
anything you're saying. Just maintain discipline. All right.
>> Is he coming? Where you going?
>> Wait, are you not going? >> Oh, Darius is suddenly
very invested in this. Wait, wait, wait. Hey, DayQuil, are you
going with us? Are you Hey, Dayquil, what are you doing? Hey,
DayQuil. What are you doing? >> Here's what I'm going to
I'm going to tell you. >> Oh, I have to get out of the
car. I have to go. Dude, it's really important I figure out what
she's doing. Okay, MC, I understand that you want to go do stuff.
It's important I figure out what she's doing first and then I'll
tell you. I'll let you >> probably day. He's got a girlfriend
now. And we've all seen it before. A streamer gets a girlfriend
or a boyfriend and then the content stops.
>> I thought we were going to come. I thought it was going
to be music playing,
vibes, something to do. I don't just want to sit there because
if >> Oh, she's landing a good attack though. This is a
good attack. Oh, Darius is a Darius is like, "Dude, I like Darius
when he's single." Dary's supposed to be dating a girl who's
not me, by the way, but Dary's supposed to be dating a girl.
And the content's going to die. >> We If I was just sitting
there talking, I could do that at home.
I came thinking we were going to do something fun. No music was
playing.
Nobody was doing anything. They went and sat on the couch and
played a [__] video game. What? Wait, Murk is trying
to break up Tazo and his girlfriend. She's a hypocrite. What?
Where is she a hypocrite there? Plant dad. How does her trying
to break up somebody trying to like cheat with someone? How does
that make her a hypocrite in this case? >> All right. To
the bridge. >> Where's your other phone? >> Oh, they're
dropping you off. >> Do nothing. Win. Do nothing. Win.
Minimal responses. Basically, no response. Just Just ignore.
Just deflect. Avoid. And she will continue to get upset.
Just smile at the camera while avoiding. She's looking at you.
You can tell she's looking at you. That's why you're smiling.
Trying. You're pretending you're trying not to smile. Okay, there's
this double there's this this double misdirect here going on.
Okay, he's pretending he's not trying to smile while he is fully
in control and smiling. I don't actually know about that. He
might be trying not to smile. Like, she's kind of staring daggers
at him. >> Dario respect her boundaries without calling
her gaslighting her and depicting her as an angry black or racially
ambiguous woman. If you'd like me to take you to the bridge.
>> Dude, is
is Merk's chat going way faster than
Why does MK have all the viewers? >> I can take you to
the bridge. >> No, I don't want to do it by myself.
>> Okay, then maybe we could set up a a >> Okay,
then I just
Okay, take me home as long as I back. Just take me home. I'm
trying to do I'm trying to like >> do interesting things.
Okay, so >> Darius is botting and has a dead community.
Um, he's definitely not botting.
Darius is not botting. Um, Darius could be botting when he has
like 300 viewers,
right? Or had an angry anti-fan bot spamming. Oh, I see. Darius
doesn't bot. I'm telling you, like when he's got bigger viewers,
when he's got like 500, 600, 700 viewers, I don't think that's
botting. That's like inbeds from DGG and then him just streaming
normally. I I look at the stats a lot. There was a period where
Darius was doing mostly desktop streams and he wasn't getting
very good metrics. He might have been botting then. But when
he actually does IRL content is like crashing out and is doing
crazy. He's got actual chatters. He's got actual engagement.
It's not botted. >> What are you guys going to do? >> He's
taking me home.
>> Yeah, he doesn't want to do anything.
>> So, this was a waste. >> Uh, he might have a dead
community. I have no idea. Honestly, like I've got a lot of overlap
with this community cuz we all like watching Dar's content. >> It
was a waste.
We all go to the Brad. You don't want to go to Brad >> and
do drink content like every there's other [__] to
do. There's other [__] I don't want to go and drink
and sit there in a bar. Okay, listen. If we go and we go to the
bar and our views go up by, let's say, 200 compared to what they
could do if we're going go hunting, then >> dude, you don't
have to go to a bar. You just have to have this fight. This fight
is going to spike your viewership.
Uh, it's totally it's like totally chaotic. It's totally
like costic. It doesn't work out long term, but this is what
gets people watching.
Nobody who watches you is a good person and just likes having
you have fun. I don't know how to say that to you guys, okay?
Not a single person in any of these communities, my community
included. Sorry. Probably a very small number of people, are
actually people who just enjoy you enjoying yourself. They want
to watch people who are like in the worst places in their lives.
That's unfortunately what this built on. You got to you just
got to acknowledge this. Okay. Just acknowledge it. >> Daryus
calls for an angry black. Let's >> just go to the Red Rooster
and just drink and do the same thing we always do and do nothing.
>> Let's go to the Red Rooster and I will fight every single
I will fight every single person in my chat and I will sit here.
I want I want to do content. I want to do something. >> Okay.
I think we were down to go to a bridge in Norwegian board. Like,
>> wait, is that the day person? There's no way that day
person is driving or something. Is she?
Why is that person talking to Merc?
>> Stop being weird and dar Ouija board. Yes, bridge. Because
Kayen didn't want it. I feel like a [__] [__]
>> Okay, we don't have to do the Ouija board. But I still
I still want to
>> Oh, she's in the back. >> Yeah, that's what we
were trying to say >> Okay, then no Ouija board, but I
still need it for other. I'm taking it with me cuz I need it.
>> So, you want to go to the bridge then? >> But
like Yeah, we don't I don't feel >> Okay, then I'll wait
for you guys in.
>> Let me try to convince him. >> Go easy on him.
He is just >> Well, I I'm not like calling anybody out.
It's usually not my downfall people are praying on, right? I'm
usually just the person watching. Not always, but usually. And
I'm just saying that I know what people I know what spikes viewership
most of the time. Okay, I know what spikes viewership. I know
what people want to watch. I've seen it. Okay, I watched everybody
watch, you know, double Destiny's viewers with Lav for that entire
arc while it was going on. Destiny being like terrible or sorry,
Destiny and Lab being terrible people to each other, right? I
watched that whole thing. I know exactly how it goes. I know
what people want in these >> We just said no Ouija board.
That was the problem. And I just said we don't have to take the
Ouija board. But I still need it. I needed to pick this stuff
up from Prawn because I go to haunted hotels. >> We hear
you, Mr. M. >> Don't sit here and try and make me the problem
here.
>> Listen, if you want to get out of streaming, if you
don't want to do this [__] anymore, that's your problem,
not mine. I'm trying to do [__] that I enjoy and
[__] that people enjoy watching. If you want to go
to a bar and you want to sit and do the same sick street content
and you want to sit there and drink, that's fine. But I enjoy
this. I enjoy doing this [__] and it does well for
my channel. So, you know, so that's you.
That's you. It's not my problem. >> Do you want to fight?
>> We can fight. We can get to We can get to Jack. >> We
can get to Jack. We can get,
>> dude. Uh, little does Merk realize Darius means literally.
He is going to start hitting her if she doesn't shut the up.
>> I'm not even joking right now cuz if I say the things
that I want to say, say what you want to say. Say it. Say it.
Dog.
Oh
[__]
Darius is going to start needling.
Uh, Merk should take this advice. Although Darius is kind of
psychotic for saying it this way. Murk should take this advice,
okay? Because I guarantee you she's the type, just knowing her,
she's the type of person who says all of her insecurities to
Darius when they're like each other and
you're totally psychotic for threatening it. If somebody gives
you information like that, you should not never weaponize it
against them out of a place of trust. It's just a disgusting
thing to do, right? But if he if he doesn't, I have no doubt
that he could say things that are going to ruin her night, ruin
her week, ruin her month. You just
double your
worry about, oh, should I be doing this with like whatever
yesterday you
because people don't [clears throat] like me and they like to
see me supper. And when I was with you and
heritage maxing out of 150 doing this, >> okay, she's she's
close. She's clo she's getting close. She knows. All right. Well,
I don't know what she's doing.
yesterday
heritage maxing out of 150 doing this [__] bridge
content. I get it, bro.
>> What's the difference? Oh, no. She does it, too. Yeah.
No, she is actually really bad for it, Sophia. Yeah, >> you
should never do that to somebody you care about. You should never
take the things like that are most personal, most most would
hurt them and then put them out in public. You shouldn't do that.
It's It's like a crazy thing to threaten in my opinion.
But I don't know. I don't like Darius Darius has male BPD so
there's just nothing that can be done right he is going to do
the same thing like him and Murk have the same diagnosis I have
diagnosed Darius personally but they have the same diagnosis
it's like he's going to do >> he's going to do what he
does you want to think >> bro you have an ego the size
>> I don't have an ego I don't have an ego but people actually
like seeing you interact with other people actually like you
seeing people that are interesting >> does have an ego
dude Are you going to let me talk? >> Does Darius have
an ego? >> Whatever, dude. >> Yes or no? Yes or no?
>> I'm not I'm not saying that like my viewers are like
the craziest [__] >> Okay, so what point are
you cuz we can have a we can have a whole debate. I know you
like [laughter] I know you like to dick suck the Destiny. So,
let's have a debate. What What is your argument?
>> that's always going to get a round of applause from
this channel. Okay. Very funny. Very funny. Thank you. Thank
you, Mark, for throwing that back out there. Thank you. Thank
you. Appreciate it. I like the face after. Okay. One day we were
just like hanging out in the living room talk like literally
doing exactly what it was before. >> But I don't want to
do I don't want to sit I want to do stuff before >> I want
to do I don't want to >> You're not listening to what I'm
saying. I don't want to sit and do nothing anymore. I want to
go out and do >> this guy is like actually I don't know
if it's BBD. This guy's got like a Patrick Baitman thing going
on. He's starting to like ruin this woman's life. He's like I
can leak things about you that'll destroy you. And then he's
like mocking into the camera. He's as selfobsessed. Do you remember
the woman who when it was like Zena and then some Russian lady
who wanted to kill herself and then some Asian woman and the
Asian woman was listening to this girl talk about how her life
is over. She wants to kill herself. Nobody loves her. Nobody
cares about her. And she was literally doing the same thing Darius
was right now. She was like looking into the camera trying to
do like the the the face trying to like uh what is it called?
Uh trying to mew into the camera, right? She was like mewing
into the camera, checking out her appearance while listening
to this person talk about how their life's over. They want to
end it. They're like having a full-blown meltdown. Zena's trying
to help them and this person is just looking at the selfie camera
and like checking their hair and checking their makeup. It's
It's crazy.
>> That's okay. That's fine. >> Okay. So, what are
you what's what point are you trying to make?
What? Just say it in one sentence. Simple, concise, and clear.
What point are you trying to make?
talking about like Oh. >> Oh, it was Moxy. Yeah, whatever.
She looked Asian. She had like the side. She had like the Emmy
room makeup on. Okay. People don't like whatever. I'm like, people
seem to be liking it. People seem to be chilling. You're the
one who seems to have the problem. >> Okay. So, if they
liked if they liked if they liked what we were doing, then why
did you have such a problem? You said I had a bad attitude. But
you said it doesn't matter cuz you're farming like you said you
were farming me. Let me finish my sentence LIKE A DOG. >> LET
ME FINISH MY SENTENCE. >> You said
farming. Let me finish LIKE A DOG. >> LET ME FINISH MY
SENTENCE. YOU said you were farming, >> dude. She like
actually spit full on there LIKE A DOG. >> LET ME FINISH
[screaming] my
>> You see it? You see? Oh,
>> this is the perfect arc. Okay,
>> that's a
it's a spitbased ICBM. Okay, that went up into the stratosphere
coming back
going to hit somewhere near Tel Aviv. >> said
you were farming regardless just like you're farming me right
now because I'm yelling and screaming and they want to see me
crash out, right? So you said we were farming regardless.
what do you mean?
What do you mean?
>> I'm not farming anything. >> That's why I'll just
point out the second she started yelling at Darius, Darius's
chat popped the off. like his chatters doubled the second she
started yelling at him.
>> She lost her point in all the yelling. Uh many such
cases. Okay. >> I just I like that Darius's chat the second
she started screaming at him, they're like, "Oh yeah, this is
what we're here for. Let's go." >> I don't I didn't want
to be stuck in my >> and I feel feel bad. I feel I feel
required to hang out with people. I can end stream right now
and if you if you want to say it's a viewer thing, I will end
stream right now. Live till I go back to my computer. >> It's
a viewer thing. >> Okay. But you just said that you brought
me the most viewers and you brought me the most money. >> Well,
I'm saying that your point of >> I'll just point out real
quick. People will get mad at me if I don't.
>> Tell her Destiny's in a fee file and not a
Tell her. Tell her that Destiny's in a fee file, not a Darius.
Darius, >> you brought me the most viewers and you brought
ME THE MOST. >> DARIUS, YOU HAVE TO TELL HIM. YOU HAVE
TO tell Burke right now. >> Well, I'm saying that your
point of oh, this is bad for me. I'm like, bro, >> wait,
what? What did you just say? The point is the point is Okay,
so let's go to the Red Rooster and do the same [__]
we do all the time instead of doing something new and like interesting
and
>> I mean, I think I don't think that your idea is bad.
>> I just you put it you asked us about it in a
>> How did I ask you about anything in a bad way? >> We
requested to do that and >> Okay, ask Shaq. What do they
think? >> We weren't ready for what do they think? What
do they think?
What is >> So I'm in the wrong because I wanted to go make
money. >> Nobody thinks you're in the wrong because So
then what's the problem? >> I'm saying in the wrong. I'm
just >> Then what's the problem, bro? I don't want to argue.
I don't care. >> He owns you because he makes you money.
>> No. You know what? You know what's crazy? You know what's
crazy? It was never about the money. And I told him that multiple
times. It was never about the money.
>> Tazo?
Who are you talking about? >> Who said anything about Tazo?
>> Dude, who the [__] are you talking about?
You said you told him that. Who's him? I
>> you know >> I was looking off at the other screen
for a second. >> What's crazy? >> It was never about
the money and I told him that multiple times. It was never about
the [__] money.
>> Tazo,
who are you talking about? >> Who said anything about Tazo?
>> Who the [__] are you talking about? You
say you told him that. Who's him? >> I'm Who am I in the
car with right now?
>> But who did you What What is about the money? What money?
>> I got here late. Why is Murk hanging out with them again
anyway? Uh cuz Murk can't not do it. She She just can't not do
it. I'm sorry. This
She'll fall back into this pattern every single time. It is what
it is. Okay.
>> Bro, okay. >> What? What are you talking about?
>> So, yeah. Let's go to the bar. Let's >> Why did
you do this, bro? This is not apt, though. This is not app. This
is You need to do this with Darius. Okay. I I appreciate it.
It's very funny. Okay.
It's very funny, but this is just Darius's identity. Okay. Darius
is the guy who can spit like like 30 feet
with accuracy.
>> Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Wrong video. Wrong video. We're
back. >> Drink. Let's get drunk. Let's do the same [__]
we always do. >> People like that. >> Yeah, people
like that. I want to I want >> And now you're gaslighting
her. >> What's wrong with doing differently
>> They don't want to. >> They don't want to. No
bridge. >> They don't even want to go anywhere now.
>> I know. And it's still
>> Are you going to go, >> dude? Are they just Are
they sitting in a car to fight? They're not even driving somewhere
yet.
They're just sitting in the car to fight.
>> So, can we please go to the bridge, make content? Or
do you want to stay here and because then I'll just
>> Yo, Marty Epstein with the three gifted. Thank you very
much, Marty. Appreciate it, dude. Appreciate you. >> Thank
you very much. >> Come on. You don't have to lie to me.
you ask your chat. Say, "What's the sub goal?" Give them a sub
goal >> for what? >> The bridge.
>> The bridge. How much for the next goal? Three more subs.
>> The bridge. Give him a sub goal and let's see if
>> he doesn't honor sub goals. M. >> That's true.
>> My fiance and J. >> That is unironically true.
So >> I just want to make content. I want to do I want
to do >> Oh, did she just turn both cameras onto
>> That's crazy. >> MC is not mentally stable enough
to be meek watching this hard. >> Okay. Okay. And then
when he does call cuz I've seen I've seen you guys will
>> Dude, why would you I just Man, I just don't get it.
Why would you sit here
and let like Darius's TTS go off like you? Like that's all it's
going to be is Darius's TTS going off you repeatedly. Like this
is this is you sit here and you let this happen. I don't know
why
>> here and say, "Oh, he does nontent. Oh, drive tent.
Oh, cleaning tent." You guys will complain about nontent, but
then when people try and do
I'm the problem.
>> Yeah, you're a woman. Okay gay. What they want is Darius
to do content on his own, to do content with women, but to want
to do content by himself. Okay. Want to do that that content,
to go and do Tinder content, to go and do something. And you
show up and you make content happen. But then they're just like,
"Oh, there's a woman on the screen. You will never be loved by
this community ever. >> I'm actually trying to do now.
I'm the problem. Venish should have never invited me.
Okay. You guys love nonsense. Well, I don't
do [__] at the bar. No,
>> you're the problem. Shut up, you dumb
>> Rick, you won this one. Okay, that guy >> because
you came and I see. >> Okay, I'm the problem. >> Genuinely,
you were better off doing your own thing. Happier and dramafree.
>> Incel love their incel king. >> Why did you come
then? >> Because I thought we were going to do be doing
something. And then when I got there, no music was playing. Everyone
was standing around.
>> That's bor. >> Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I do
have to stop. Why did you keep pointing out new no music was
playing? That's like a fixable problem. Hey, this is kind of
boring. Can we put some music on? What the Why is this being
hampered on or harped on repeatedly? What are we doing? >> And
then when I got there, no music was playing. Everyone was standing
around. That's boring.
So, I was like, "Okay, let's play a drinking game." Darius >> "You
were jealous of Shabbama?"
The point is I came. I was like, "Okay, well, we'll come. We'll
make some content. Whatever.
We're doing nothing. No music's playing." I said, "Okay, let's
play." And we can we can fact check this. I said, "Okay, well,
let's play a drinking game." And he says, "Oh, I have no ideas."
And I was like, "Okay, well then let's go to a bridge. I know
a bridge that's haunted. We could do like some haunted content
>> hunting over bars." >> You were treating Darius
the way you want to treat Cath. These people, These people don't
understand.
I I get it, okay? They think, Listen, if we do really fun stuff
and we're having a great time, everybody will enjoy it. No. Wrong.
If you're having fun, you will get fewer viewers. I promise you,
if they went out and they did like a really funny haunted stream,
nobody would care. Nobody would watch it. Zena did an awesome
uh what do you call it? Like she went and did some abandoned
like theme park,
what would you call it? Like urban exploration stream. It was
actually cool. It was actually funny. She literally got a like
a dumbbell thrown at her. Not a dumbbell. Like a like a what
do you call it? Like a standard sized weight thrown at her by
some crazy homeless person. I think she had like 200 viewers
for that stream. But when she crashes out and starts like talking
about people, she gets like 700 viewers, 800 viewers. The people
aren't there to have you watch you have fun. They're there to
watch you melt down. They're there to watch you have bad times.
If you give them good times, they won't care. That will be content.
as a listen girl. Get over him. >> So what do you want?
So what do you want? You want me to sit there and >> you
still like him? >> No. That is so annoying. Okay. >> Oh,
that's the that's the one that it's going to catch her. You still
like him.
>> You want me to sit there and >> You still like
him? >> No. [sighs] That is so annoying. Okay. So, it's
going to get to a point where I just I just don't hang out cuz
here's the thing. I get told I'm a bit for not hanging out with
people. >> He's farming you. >> Okay, so then Oh,
Kirby just messaged him. Let's see what Kirby said. >> Oh,
[laughter] wait.
Wait. He left his phone on. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Kerafi just started messaging him. Oh
He left his phone unlocked right next to Merc. And the only way
he'd get a message letting him know that happened is by having
his phone on him. Uhoh.
Oh >> Let's see what Kirby said. I never said I'm broke,
by the way. I have good money. Hi Kirby. Are you watching? That's
not true. You said on >> ass acting like he wasn't cliffing
since you walked in. So you popped attitude >> she's she's
about to full on parry this guy. Okay.
>> The Perry 3 maneuver. All right. She got left alone
with the unlocked devices. Time to read some messages. >> Last
you because they weird. Uh >> we can look at Prawn's dating
stream. >> again, thank you for the It was great. >> Yeah,
we can pull up the receipts.
We can pull up the receipts if you want.
I'm pretty sure he posted VODs on YouTube. You literally said
you don't like me because you said >> we want haunted tent.
>> I'm out here struggling. I'm broke, fighting, trying
to make money. That's why you don't like me.
That's exactly what you said. That's exactly what you said. So,
the only thing is I have no problem with you. I just don't like
people lying. Okay. What is she saying now?
Uh, that's funny cuz my parents have eight. Okay. So, why was
my problem? Why was the problem that you had with me? Because
you said you were struggling and I will go
and pull up. >> Why do we look like a male? >> Talk
about it.
>> Do you have to pay a subscription fee for the internet
or is it just like
>> for unlimited [snorts]
>> So turn off your phone service and then just like try
it. >> I pay for unlimited
>> double stop. >> So do you have the clips or not?
>> Uh a lot of talk was Nova's feet. You can clip a what?
>> We can find it. Is that a vape?
>> it's a Starling cord. >> My thing is, dude, [clears throat]
>> Dude, I don't read anything. >> You don't read.
That's unfortunate. >> Um, she was reading your messages
with >> Kirby said Kirby's like blowing up, by the way.
She >> um, she was reading your messages with >> Yeah,
I was. >> Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Wait, she didn't read like that much off. I thought it was going
to be way worse than that. I thought she was going to go back
and read a whole bunch of. She barely did anything. That could
have been so much worse. But now maybe Darius's going to freak
out about it. >> Open up my text messages. >> She
was reading your messages with code. >> Why were you doing
that? >> It was on the screen. Oh, it's farming, right?
Like it's still >> No, if you click it, you can open. >> Oh,
I didn't I didn't open it. I didn't exit out of this. >> Oh,
how did you see it? >> It's right there. >> Well,
it just says curb message you. It doesn't say like >> I
have it set up. I have it set up so I do not get text. >> I
go like this and then it shows >> and then you read it
and so you >> Yeah, I did. >> Okay. What did it say?
>> She said >> she didn't expect Darius to know what
his notification settings were. Okay. She thought she could get
away with a little fib. No, I didn't do anything. I It just popped
right up. No, it didn't. I haven't said not to do that. Oh, yeah.
I clicked on it. Maybe a little bit. Maybe
broke, by the way. I make um eight figures a year or something.
And her parents make a lot of money. >> I clicked it. She's
lying. >> No, I just >> I make eight figures a year
or something. Wait, wait. What? >> Okay. What did >> she
said? Uh, I never felt broke, by the way. I make um eight figures
a year or
>> Kerbine definitely didn't say that. Okay. Kerbine did
not say she makes eight figures.
If if she makes eight figures, Darius would have zero problems.
Darius would straight up marry her. Okay. Like immediately, Darius
would have no more problem. He would be like, "Oh, I'm done streaming.
Oh, I'm a house husband now." If she made eight figures a year,
okay, I promise you that would be the case. >> And her
parents make a lot of money. She's lying. >> No, I just
I literally just said that I looked at it. I'm not scared. >> You
have to click it in order. >> No, I don't have to click
it. Watch. Kirby, she's watching right now. Hold on. I'll prove
it. I'll show you. I'll show you exactly what I did. Kirby text
problem when she clipped her text again. >> You're weird.
So, why the would they give me this?
>> There's no USBC convers.
Darius just wants to get his Starling figured out. Okay. Darius
doesn't give a about your book. Reading his text. He doesn't
give a All right. Just Just let me figure out something. >> Oh,
is this a converter? >> Say hello. >> Cafe. Thank
you for the 10 bucks. >> No, she's not going to do it.
>> Darius, we can give you a clip. She's
>> I'm not lying. I just said I drugg it >> I I >> was
worried about that. So, that's
>> With stalker art. >> You drugg it down, which
is still That's >> Yeah, but I didn't. You said I clicked
it and it opens it up. I never left
>> Okay. If she texts again, I can show you what I did.
>> I know what you did. >> Okay. So, you got a problem
with it? Okay, I don't care. Next.
>> Hey guys, Phil here. Come on down to the ranch and work
on this toxic >> So, can we make content or no? Or are
you going to drop me off? >> She's red color now. >> No,
you're tweaking. >> I'm tweaking? Yeah. >> I don't
think she said eight figures >> because now I'm not letting
treat me >> he was able to fit in Darius. I don't give
a I This is how >> you open his messages like he open the
only reason it's a problem day is because people can't benefit
>> he's still like literally not paying attention to her.
He's like not even really getting that mad about the messages.
He's just letting her crash out cuz he's trying to while he figures
out Starlink. Okay. He's figured out a way. He's just going to
make money. He doesn't even have to doesn't have the camera on
him. He's just sitting there figuring out Starlink while she
crashes out about his TTS.
It's like a money printing machine anymore because I'm actually
send another text if you send >> Oh my god, the TTS. >> I'm
b I would be benefiting. >> I am literally
I'm not letting anyone I I'm very combative now. >> You're
giving him what he wanted. >> Good, good, good. So, can
we go to the
>> Down. Just keep looking for the ghost.
>> Let me take my phone real quick anymore. >> I
need to just grab this cord first so I can test it out. The TTS
is free, too, by the way. It's free, but it's only for subs,
right? Only subs can TTS.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Be right back. >> Make content
in the house. No.
>> Boring. No music playing. >> This is definitely
foreplay.
>> Any bets on who gets the DV charge?
>> Darius, be careful not treating you like >> Yeah.
Do you want >> Didn't leave his phone in the car this time,
though. Okay. not making that same mistake twice.
He made sure he took it with him this time. Do >> you want
to take the ones I'm wearing right now? Hey man, you need >> No,
she's crashing the out. She's going through my phone and [__]
dude.
>> Ry, is there any example what MK's saying at this time?
You run the back.
>> Got I got the wrong audio for this part. Let me grab
the time stamp if you want to hear MK. I do want to hear MK.
So, we'll listen to Darius for a second
We'll listen to merch. We'll listen to Darius for a little bit
and then we'll listen to merchand
still figuring out Starlink.
>> Oh my god,
I am lit.
>> I want to
I want to leave this [__] house. >> Is this
the same girl that was at uh was it TwitchCon that they went
to where Darius cut his hand? That was that Yeah, that was at
TwitchCon. Oh,
is that the same girl that was there with Prawn at
Wait, how did she get to Austin?
Why is she there from Or was she in Austin anyway and she flew
with them to TwitchCon or went with them to >> I'm going
to put up my other bun.
Friday. Friday night was nothing but the
>> Friday night?
>> I just like going on vendors, >> dude. It's I'll
be honest, even without the audio working, we will go back and
watch the Merc audio real quick, but without the audio working,
it's like everybody in the house is very chill. You've got Merc
just like
having a full-blown solo queen in the car. Just like having her
total having her villain rant over the car, >> too. And
>> everybody in the house, Xans the out. Mark in the car.
Okay. Operating on a different level just like me out. Okay.
Wild stuff. Hold on. And let's pull this
>> You the way she wants to.
>> I never said that. You guys are lying. >> Oh,
she's just fighting with her own TTS now. I see. >> It's
so funny how everyone wants to say I'm nonsense. I'm nontent.
I'm non tent. And now that I'm actually trying to do and do things
that are exciting and things I enjoy. It's a problem. Oh, so
I know this is what he wants. He
>> uh this girl by the way the the girl inside Dayquil
was somebody who Frances met on Twitter. >> What you drinking
Dayquil Darius Darius says he's not dating her not her purely
because he totally stole her from Prawn the same way he stole
Hannah from Rei. Darius is always looking to
uh what is it called? Uh to dirty Mac on his boys. Okay. Darius
is always looking to dirty Mac on his boys all the time. He will
do whatever he can. He he's okay. He's up. So he
he took this girl from prawn. He doesn't want to say he's her
obviously. Okay. He is like Drake. He is like Drake. Okay.
The I don't know man. It's up. So
in any case,
>> Marty, this is the girl he's with now. I now am one
of your top three donors. Summon the others to my Tel Aviv estate
immediately. We must
align our messaging. >> Align our messaging.
>> Do not waste. >> Do not waste my investment. >> I
don't know what happened with the DS there, but thank you for
the 15. That's another hour on the stream, right?
Oh, whoops. Or we'll we'll throw that up there right now. Boom.
Boom. Okay.
So, that's who this girl is. Um, she was also with them at TwitchCon,
but she had met Prawn at TwitchCon and was like, "Hang out there."
And Darius was like hitting on her aggressively while in the
room with Prawn. And she was clearly more into Darius than Prawn
says. It was very weird. It was very awkward.
I don't know, man. It was it was pretty
it was pretty brutal to watch. I'm not going to lie to you, okay?
That she was like PR's date and Darius was like literally ignoring
girls who wanted to him who were in the room. Like I think Herbopene
wanted to him while they were there
and and Darius did not give a Darius was only focused on this
girl.
Yeah, it's very interesting stuff. Okay, interesting dynamics.
Anyway, we go back to the MC rant. Okay, Murk is ranting while
this is all >> me to be upset and cry
and complain and now that I don't give a
stroking his ego and you guys know it. If you are an adult and
you live in the real world, you know exactly what's going on.
He doesn't like that I don't give a [__] anymore.
And that's exactly what it is. That's exactly what it is.
you showed up. You can't you can't cap, okay? You can't cap about
being not infatuated or whatever. You don't care anymore. You
can't say that when you're here mad that he won't go out with
you. You did your makeup. You got dressed up. You went over to
his house. You drove 45 minutes to do it. And then you say, "Well,
he's mad I don't care about him anymore." No, he knows you care
about him. He knows exactly why you're there, what you're doing.
Uh he probably thinks it's very funny when you say you don't
It's uh Listen, it's very goofy. Okay.
And if he would have told me
cuz even I was in his chat on the way. I was like, "Why is no
music playing? Why is nothing going on?" If I wanted to sit here
with nothing going on,
>> I would have just stayed home.
>> But we're here now. We need to do something. And I offered
multiple. I was like, "Let's play drinking games. Let's play
the Ouija board. Let's do something. It will just be okay. >> If
you guys want to sit here and go to the bar, I don't want to
go to the bar.
I've seen streams you people wouldn't believe. Destiny caught
with Das driving while Zena screams. Kelly Jean commentary on
Westbank documentaries. All those memes will be lost in time
like tears in >> I walked away for a second. Thank you
very much Gummy Verse.
Thank you. Thank you very much Gummy Verse for the What was that?
20. Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate it, buddy. >> I can
drink at home. I can go to Sixth Street. Sixth Street's boring.
I'm tired of drunk content. I'm try I'm tired of drinking and
not doing [__] I want to actually do
>> and ghost content is something that I enjoy now because
[music] it's fun. It's exhilarating. I want to >> Oh, so
this is a thing she's been doing for a while. Ghost content.
I don't know what ghost content is. >> [__]
I want to go I want [music] to do
and just like just like on the the the RV,
he didn't do anything.
Nothing's happening. I want to do [__] Like what?
And so you're gonna sit here and blame me?
You're gonna blame me? Like what? >> I think so. I understand
where she's coming from a little bit. Okay, I get it that like
abandoned locations. There are a lot of places Well, there were
a lot of places in Florida, but there are a lot of places in
in in the States where Yeah. stuff's just totally abandoned.
you go at night, you like it's like kind of like a spooky vibe.
It can be like funny, but it's usually just like especially for
a streaming experience. Imagine it's very dark. You can barely
see anything and then you just like all the enjoyment you get
is out of the streamers going, "What was that? What was that?"
It's it's like
Now, hold on. When the homeless people were stalking Zena,
that was crazy. Okay, that was like some wild stuff. I didn't
know about that when it happened, though. I never heard about
that through the stream. Zena came on and described it to me.
She like came on stream and described it to me and I was like,
"Oh, that sounds like really funny. Can you give me a link?"
And she gave me a link and we watched it together.
But it was crazy.
It was like the director's
>> No, I have no I have no I'm saying this publicly. I
have no interest in Darius. Okay. I just want to make content.
That's it.
>> Imagine I had my soundboard and it said, "Stop the cap.
Stop the cap. Stop. Stop the cap. >> People will complain
whether you do or don't mirk. That's why you put yourself
>> I want to do I don't want to sit here and drink. I don't
want to drink. And the only reason I drink is cuz it's boring.
So let Oh, okay. Well, I'm bored. Let me drink. It's kind of
like people who eat when they're bored. It's the same thing.
Like, okay, well then I'll just sit here and drink. I want to
Yeah, I did. [__] him.
I said I'm no longer interested in him.
Dude, holy [__]
I The sounds of Darius getting into the car here. Holy. I thought
that was coming from in my house. That was freaky to me. I heard
like the knock and I I was like listening with one headphone
out and then I closed it back up and he knocked again immediately
out of my left headphone. Freaked me the out interested or not
interested in it. >> I'm responding my I'm not even talking
to you, bro. I'm talking to them. >> Letting you know.
>> Just letting you know. Is this too fat? Can you ban
that guy? I'm tired of I'm tired of the yapping. >> Okay,
this is Darius gone back into the house at this point. >> No,
ma'am.
>> Wait until Dar Darius got the phone
Going back out to the caring
to you, bro. I'm talking to >> being interested or not
interested in >> It I'm responding my I'm not even talking
to you, bro. I'm talking to >> Okay. Okay. Here we go.
>> Letting you know.
>> Just letting you know. Is this too fat? >> Can
you ban that guy? I'm tired of I'm tired of the yapping. I don't
give a >> Wait, so it does work. Okay. Is there a port
over there for a chance?
>> All right, let's see if this works on the Starlink chat.
I can let you use it if you want. >> I'm good. I have good
service. >> There's good service there. >> Yeah,
unless you want to go somewhere there's no service. If you're
trying to test it, you should go outside of Terry Blacks cuz
Terry Blacks is an F zone. He knows if he pushes your buttons,
it'll feed his chat what they want at the detriment of your well-being.
>> Who's saying that?
>> Hey, I mean, who's giving the game away? Wait, stop
giving the game away. No spoilers. No spoil. Who Who said that?
Who's giving spoilers? >> That's why I said just turn your
phone on airplane mode and use Wi-Fi only and then it'll prove
if it works or not.
>> We can do that. >> You need to be alpha. Okay,
there's the actual botting that's happening. >> Shut up.
Shut up and sit down. Merk shoved a battery pack up her coochie
while reading your text from Kirby.
>> Yeah, I did. Okay. >> You want to go with us?
>> We're going to the bridge. >> The bridge.
>> You want to go with us? Go with us? We're going to the
bridge.
>> Nah, man. I'm going to go home. Bye.
>> What are you What are you guys doing at the bridge?
>> What are you doing at the bridge? You're just going
to hang out. >> You and Darius are just going to hang out
at the bridge.
>> On stream.
>> So, if I go along
>> and something happens, how am I getting >> Well,
you can follow us. >> Oh, okay. Yeah. >> Wait, where
do you live? >> Did you walk inside and instantly
work looking at your phone? >> Near the airport?
>> Where do you live?
>> Like north of town. >> Well, you're coming back
here, right? After you drop me off.
>> Yeah. Okay, then he can drop you back off at your car.
>> Darius, you going to drop me back off at my car?
>> Dude, I I'm sorry. Nobody who's driving. It sounds like
Darius is driving. Just nobody was driving before. Um,
it sounds like this guy just doesn't want to go. And you ever
get in that mode where this is like the worst case scenario,
okay? You never want to be this person. somebody doesn't want
to do something but they give you like a a total excuse like
some reason some some way that's like they don't want to say
no I'm like tired I don't want to hang out with you because that's
like a indictment of you so they're like no like I live far away
and it's like inconvenient
and you're like well I can solve that and you keep solving their
problems and it just becomes more obvious they just don't want
to hang out that guy just wants to go to bed man >> here
yeah I had to bring Jake back too >> all right how long
y'all going to be out >> not that long probably
not that And now this guy's just like, "Why didn't I just Why
didn't I just say I didn't want to go?" God damn it.
>> I imagine. >> So, I'm ready for the one thing
you appreciate about each other.
>> Ready for digging?
>> What's up? >> Yeah. I know chat's being like really
mean to you right now. >> I just I want to make content.
If it's not content related, I don't want to do anything else.
>> The content is you being yourself. >> No, I content
related. >> Yeah. No chats being like really mean to you
right now. >> I want to make content. If it's not content
related, I don't want to do anything else.
>> I I saw this and I was like, "Dude, what's the sloth
thing we got going on right now?" He's got his head tilted.
>> The content is you being yourself. >> No, I >> I
think you might actually just be really exhausted. His eyes are
like not closed the same amount. This happens to me if I get
really tired, right? I think probably happens to a lot of people.
Your eyes get dry and then you realize like one eye is like half
closed. You don't even realize it. >> That's not what I
want to do. I want to go somewhere and do what I want to do.
and do something fun. >> Hey,
today's all about you, M. >> It should be.
>> Thank you. >> No Ouija boards, please. >> No
Ouija boards.
No Ouija board. >> Merk, the content is in your heart.
>> We'll probably check this out at some point here. Uh,
pugging ups. Although, 4 hours. I don't know why people debate
for this long. It really shouldn't take that long. >> Is
no Ouija boards or anything, bro?
>> No Ouija boards or anything. It'll be fun. You said
what? >> No Ouija boards or anything. We're just going to
go. >> He asked if you wanted your plate. >> I'll
have my plate. >> Your plate?
>> Connor lost his mind.
>> Yeah. Connor probably doesn't like debating conservatives
because he just constantly gets thrown in his face that he's
a total hypocrite loser.
He doesn't really like debating any of those people. They just
constantly call him like a hypocrite loser and then he just crashes
out. >> You can jump. Wait, where are we jumping to? Oh,
Darius gets back out. >> I'll drive. Let's be chill. >> I'll
drive. No. [laughter]
>> Which girl gets the white tea tonight? >> White
tea on a bridge.
>> Let's uh let's skip forward a little >> All right.
Who's got GPS? >> It's just a bridge of wood, but by night,
spirits cry in the flood. A man in the rafters. His soul bounds
tight. The news still scrapes in the dead of >> Your former
cuddle buddy. We should get dinner with Lauren the Laguna sometime.
>> I would love to get dinner with Lauren. If Lauren would
like to get dinner, we can get dinner. Hm. >> Lauren's
nice to me. >> Does anybody have GPS?
Anybody have a phone I can use? You got a charger?
>> Does he have her one? >> Yeah, we can. >> I
think you forgot something in the house. Darius, >> you
have a car?
>> Darius is like showing his actual black roots here.
Okay, I'm going to say I'm going to say what we all see is going
on. Darius is showing how black he has become. Okay, the crimes
have transformed him genetically. He's now deciding that instead
of like a a tall, skinny black woman,
he just wants like a random fat white stoner. Not fat. I don't
want to be a total [__] but like she's bigger. Okay,
she's bigger. All right, he's he's been changed. Okay, he's become
every He should honestly hit up Pearl right away.
He should hit up Pearl for real.
>> Can I charge my phone right now? >> I could just
drive, you know. >> Well, I can get to my phone. I'm totally
not getting 5 years in prison. >> I'll use my other phone.
Give me two seconds. [laughter]
>> You're starting to troll. >> Oh boy.
>> Have you seen the sniff picture yet? Yes. Gross. Okay.
That one is just an observation. Frank. Okay.
This girl's body fat is like double what Merks is. MK is like
skinny. MK's looking really good. She got all dressed up. This
person is like roughing it in a hoodie.
Not anywhere she lives. Okay. Wasn't planning to go over to hang
out.
It's like a total difference. And and Marcus, that's going to
[__] with somebody's self-esteem, obviously.
>> Oh, you darling. >> I don't think this woman's
like ugly. I'm not saying she's ugly. I was probably a little
too But I It's so on stream, Frank. But now you've made me do
it. It's okay for me to go, well, this woman's like heavier than
Murk. I don't think she's unattractive, but she's like heavier.
It's just easier to just say that fat white woman. Okay, it's
for the joke. But then you're like, I think you're like really
mean to women sometimes. It's like, well, if it's for the sake
of a joke, maybe could happen.
>> Will more likes active. Tell him to be prawn first for
that black ass party.
>> Are you a little >> Merk would say Darius or Tazo
is better at cuddling?
>> Uh, well, >> I vision.
You just
[__] me and then basically
more than like I don't care looking like a [__] >> She's
extremely stoned. She's not mad or
>> Wait, who? The person. I didn't say the person in the
back was mad.
>> Mk is definitely mad though. She's not extremely stoned.
Or >> I mean I I hope you're not talking about Murk. She's
clearly mad too. >> And then I would like try and like
cuddle and you'd be like, "Yeah, I'm >> Revealing details.
Not good. >> And then I would like try and like cuddle
and you'd be like, "Yeah, I'm good." Yeah. >> I don't know
what you're talking about. >> You're so cold. Furious.
>> Again, why is Brooklyn juice still here? Ban this guy.
>> I don't think I don't think that's a good thing to do.
Maybe that's why I don't think I did the >> Joe Rogan made
a funny joke and you banned him. Free him immediately or I will
get the Supreme Court involved. >> You just said I'm not
a liar. So either I'm a liar sneaky Mr. Harious wipe your nose
like smoke.
>> Oh, misremembering. Gotcha.
>> All right. Yeah. Uh considering um the countless times
that I would like literally beg you to hold me and then I would
have to Uber because you weren't getting the attention and I
require afterare because uh stuff is a trigger for me which is
why I don't do much.
>> BRO, STOP. STOP. M STOP. M STOP. You got to stop. Don't.
Dude, don't do this. Oh, this is not good. Not a good look.
Not a good look. Not a good look. Not a good look at all. Give
me a second because now I need my if I'm gonna I need my soundboard
for this. Okay. There's just crazy things being said. >> Oh,
misremembering.
>> All right. Yeah. Uh considering um the countless times
that I would like literally beg you to hold me and then I would
have to Uber because you weren't giving me attention. And I require
afterare because uh stuff is a trigger for me which is why I
don't give >> Are we talking about [__] [__]
are we doing the bridge thing guys? Um, and I would have sex
with you, meaning that it would make you like me more and get
in a relationship with me. Um, but you were still in love with
other people and talking to Hannah the entire time. So, >> it's
really oversharing, but I mean, I think all of this was known.
I don't know if this is Yeah, do nothing. Do nothing. Get all
of your details leaked. >> You wouldn't do those things,
which made me leave because you wouldn't hold me. You wouldn't
cuddle me. You wouldn't treat me like a girlfriend. You wouldn't
give me the afterare that I require. And if you know anything
about like you would know that some women require a lot of afterare
being one of them. >> Joe Rogan made a funny joke. >> So
now you're gonna give something that makes me look bad to invalidate
what I'm
>> Hold on. Oh yeah, that that came through right for stream.
>> I don't see it coming through for stream. Oh yeah, it
is. >> But did you hold me? No. And I ended up sleeping
on the couch most of the times or just leaving and I have the
bank account.
Um, I mean, if she says this is what she needs during, I do think
it's kind of up if she's like, "Hey, I don't know." Again, unless
we unless we cuddle after because it makes me feel like used
or bad. Probably that's something you should be able to commit
to before you have sex. >> The dates and times cuz I cataloged
when we had on my period app. >> So, if you're trying to
say, "Oh, that didn't happen." I can show you when I Ubered,
what time I Ubered, and uh where
know what I'm told. Yeah, >> Lake Flugerville. you know
about >> we're not going to wait for >> you left
her in that car you made that
>> Hey, I apologize if I get the >> Well, it's too
late now. That's why I just uh just want to make Clinton. I don't
give a [__] about anything else. >> I agree.
>> So, yeah. >> I just
I'm just not someone that's >> protecting Darius from a
Joe Rogan made a funny joke and you banned him. Free him immediately.
>> Okay, buddy. >> I will get the supreme.
>> Okay, buddy. Whatever makes you feel better about yourself.
>> Whatever makes you feel better about yourself. I don't
care. Whatever makes you feel You're so right, Darius. You are
right. I'm wrong. I'm a liar. I'm >> I'm just incredibly
affectionate.
>> I require >> But I But I listen. Maybe that >> Okay,
buddy. Whatever.
>> Maybe maybe it's not do nothing win. Maybe it's do nothing
and you get to have like They both look done.
Huh? Maybe they're not winning.
>> Seems like no one's winning. >> Gave me his switch,
but he didn't have the he didn't have a farm save. So, I'm
chill form
just tonight. >> In my account, I have Animal Crossing
on that thing. >> Did Audrey really make you get rid of
the Adri voice? >> No, you put it back. I just took it
off while car chicken. >> Damn. bank statements. >> It's
so good though. It's so good.
>> Yeah, because this is what you have to do because people
will sit here and make you look like you're a liar or that you're
crazy. I have receipts upon receipts upon receipts. I've got
my bank statement saved.
Are you like dumb? Like I'm sorry. Do you think you're getting
a Uber?
>> Dude, Darius gets triggered by the weirdest things
like MC talking about like how he was like not caring after he
like basically stays calm. He goes, "I have my bank account receipts
saved." He like suddenly he's like, "What the are you two stupid
you stupid?
What are you talking about?" >> Means you're not getting
what you need. You got an Uber randomly. You left like two times
randomly in the middle of the night. I don't know. >> Because
you wouldn't I told you there's a trigger for me because >> that's
a that's you told me just now. You didn't tell me at the time.
I did. I >> No, you did not. >> BECAUSE ANYTIME I
TRIED to have any kind of conversation about anything like that,
you're saying I'm crashing out or I'm crazy. So, I didn't bring
it up.
>> Just because I didn't bring it up even just because
I didn't even have this conversation right now. I'm not telling
you you're crashing out or crazy. >> Well, it's over. Can
we go to the bridge? It's over. I don't care. >> Okay.
I'm just saying that you're >> It's time. >> You're
trying to make a pattern of behavior with me that this doesn't
>> No, I'm not trying to make any pattern. I'm telling
you my experience.
>> Okay. So, that either I'm >> I mean, the pattern
totally aligns in that Darius literally never cares about another
person unless it's testy. basically just does not give a about
any other people. Like basically is a persistent pattern. I don't
think he's like a persistent Well, I don't know. The other stuff
I'll let Mark prove out. Okay. Jesus. Absolute like gigachad
jaw lying going on here. Damn,
dude. That is epic. Revealed the craziest jawline. Holy [__]
>> I'm lying or am I lying or telling the >> I just
brought something up and I'm not calling you crazy or telling
you you're just crashing. I didn't say you were right now.
>> But I'm telling you this is how I talk to you. I don't
usually talk to you like that. So I don't know how you think
that's okay. None of this matters. The point is that's what happened.
That's how I felt.
>> I can see that I understand. >> So what does what
does any of this matter? Because we're not talking
>> I tried to tell you how you made me
>> and you said that it it wasn't that deep or like oh
you're crashing out for no >> You would tell me that like
you can't breathe without me and [__] I never
wa Okay, now you're lying. [laughter]
>> Now, I would never I would never suspect that Darius
is lying with that, but he's like already smiling as she calls
him out. Like, I feel like I feel like this face by itself is
enough for me to go.
I feel like he might be
recycling some Xeno lines to you. That that sounds like something
Zena would say. You said that it wasn't that deep or like Oh,
you're crashing out for no >> because you would tell me
that like you can't breathe without me. And >> I never
Okay, now you're lying. >> Now you're lying. Okay. And
it's my word against yours. So, you know what? I'm going to let
you have it. >> Go through the text. >> I think we
should go through the texts. Can we go through the texts? Say
>> pull the text in. Pull up the text right >> Pull
the text. >> Pull the text. >> This is a This is
a 40 chess move by Darius. He's confused her with Zena or some
other woman and he is now going to go through and go, "Oh, I
guess you didn't send that. I wonder who sent that to me."
Is it It's an investment in a future in a future meltdown. Okay,
>> cuz I know exactly what the [__] I said
and I made sure to screenshot it because I don't know cuz like
a lot of people like to like delete [__] and why
you press in
let the homie grip that heavy chick moving like 12 China never
had BBW
and it shows. Thank you very much for the little tariff. That
is that Oh, that is the little tariff voice. Okay. Well, that
is true. Or better words, >> I had a crush on you. I liked
you and I I felt wrong because, you know, I don't want to start
something that I can't finish. Uh, but I never said the words
I cannot breathe without you. I never said that. I know for a
fact I never said that. So, if you would like to produce an exact
screenshot, hold on. No, no, no, no, no. Act like we're in a
court of law right now. If you can produce the exact message
of me saying I cannot breathe without you. >> I don't think
you said that exactly. >> Oh, so now I didn't. Now you're
moving the goal post. >> Dude, why does MC always mogs
him in in debates every single time? Darius loses like every
debate to Murk. Every single time your breath might make you
feel like you're losing your breath. >> That's gay. I would
never say that.
>> That's why you said I would never say >> That's
That's >> gay. Okay, you have it. Cuz guess what? It's
my word against yours. You're not I can prove I don't care what
you can win. I'm crazy. I'm the one who's too in deep. Oh, I'm
sorry that the minute someone puts their dick in me, I think
that they like me. And the only reason that you wanted to just
hook up and you didn't actually do anything.
Okay, let's pull up your Discord messages right now. >> I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
>> I No, no, no. I'm going to pull it up. No, you're right.
>> I don't know what you're saying. >> Hey, hold
on. I just saw the DayQuil person in the kick chat. Hold on.
What did she say? She typed a message here. I got to go. TTS
play I Can't Breathe by Peter Parker Mcllum. Daycool 69. Is that
her typing in the chat talking while she's in the back seat?
>> IRL. No, no, no. I'm going to pull it up. No, you're
right. I'm going to pull it up. >> You did not want to
[__] anymore.
>> No, I'm going to prove it. I'm going to prove it. That's
fine. You want to say
that? Okay. I'm telling you something that was verbally. >> Let's
look at the messages. >> I'm telling you something that
was verbally communicated. Nope. Nope. Nope. Cuz guess what?
What I say in messages are the same thing I say. >> The
person you literally said it's
going to be hook up cuz I'm not trying to let me read this. Let
me read this for your chat. You're an inconsiderate jerk. That's
all you care about. Not my feelings. Letting your community call
me crazy, telling lies, acting like you've done nothing wrong.
Genely genuinely all I wanted to do was spend time together and
do things together and be near you. I liked you. I don't understand
you. I don't know why I couldn't have been enough. Why couldn't
you like me back? And what's even crazier is I didn't even like
you in the first place. I wish I didn't catch feelings. But when
I haven't felt like this in years, what do you expect? You make
me look stupid. You play in my face. I know feelings are difficult,
especially when you've been with someone so long. You didn't
even try though. You didn't try and you did so many things that
made me feel like I had a chance.
>> Dude, what the Jesus?
I What? I Dude, this person is like from the back seat. And I
see her in the chat from the back seat.
And also, this is just very sad. This is this is just sad to
watch. How is this proof? Um, it's proof that she I mean, she's
basically just saying the same thing as before.
I mean, also,
it's hard to feel this bad when she had every indication that
this wasn't going to work, right?
Like, there's every indication that Darius is not able to like
maintain stable long-term relationships after Sushia, I guess.
>> I thought I could have taken care of you. That's all
I wanted to be there for you and make you happy. And no, no,
no. Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me finish. No, let me finish.
Let me finish. No, Darius, let me finish. And I said, and forget
about everything. So, yes, continue to lie. Continue to let people
think I'm crazy or worse uh worse than Zena. In the end, I know
who I am. I know how I feel. And I know how I was will respond
and conduct myself. I can't even stream because I'm so embarrassed.
Everyone is laughing at me. I've been sick throwing up because
of how much I've been crying. You You My heart is broken. You
hurt me. I wish I could have detached. I wish I could have ignored
my feelings. I wish I could be cool about
a This is This is actually brutal. Like I Dude, Darius is in
a rough spot. Isn't Darius in love with Zena? Um I have no idea.
I have no idea to be honest.
He could he'd run back to Zena immediately. I have no idea. Seems
he's still in love with Zena. Zena. I don't I don't know where
this narrative is coming from. I think he's not over Zena, but
it's not because it's love. It's because Zena like walked away
from him, I think. Although then that ended weirdly. I can't
even remember the last place it >> Not at all. Then maybe
I could still be around you. And the fact that I think that way
is sick. The fact I want to blame myself or wish I could be heartless
is sick. I'm so sick. You hurt me so bad. And the fact you can
continue as normal and not be upset. I was innocent in this.
All I wanted was you. Now, let me continue. There's more. I'll
I'll just say as far as like breakup messages go and
that's not even like that's not weird. That's that's like pretty
normal. I would think
it feels pretty normal to me. It's just weird to read it on a
live stream. That's about it. But like I totally understand how
she feel that way. Darius seemed to like I unfortunately made
content out of it. Was Darius like just ignoring her seemingly
pretty intentionally like trying to break her self-esteem? trying
to make her like freak out on stream. Um, he succeeded.
Huge W for Darius. He got exactly what he wanted. This is exactly
what he wanted the whole time, right? >> You understand?
>> There's more. >> You just want to talk about this
stuff.
>> Oh, defending myself is wanting to talk about even defending
yourself. It's not >> It's weird when they didn't even
date though. It's weird for her to say that like she wanted to
date and she feels like not loved or valued. I feel like it's
not weird. It might not be like what would you call it? It might
not be like it might not make sense. There might have been every
indication it wouldn't have worked,
but it's like she can have those feelings and express those feelings
to the other person. I just think it's weird to make them
But I I don't think it's weird for her to say those things to
Darius or write them down.
In fact, I think it's like the most healthy thing to write them
down and not send them to anybody. That's what we call putting
in the pit. >> Related to the point. >> Nothing related.
>> Yes. Take me home. Take me home. I take me home. Take
me home before. >> Put your address in here and say >> um
you can just drop me off at uh where you parked your car on in
downtown
>> cuz I don't I don't want anyone in my
>> And this is exactly what you wanted. >> No, I
didn't.
>> I mean, this is exactly what he wanted. She is totally
correct there. This is 100% exactly what he was going for,
right? I'm sorry. There's
He didn't have to do like a bunch of weird with another woman
on stream. He freaked the out when Zena did this to him. He knows
exactly exactly
what uh like what it felt like when Zena did it to him. You missed
another day message. It's just the same one again. But no, it's
the same message. Prawn play I can't breathe by Peter Park. >> And
this is exactly what you wanted. >> No, I didn't. >> This
is exactly what you got what you wanted. So I'm glad you got
what you >> dude. I thought we were just >> No, I'm
glad you got what you wanted. I'm glad you got what you wanted.
>> Like I don't I don't necessarily feel like bad for anyone
here. Everybody knew exactly how this was all going. But if Darius
is like, "No, this isn't what I wanted." I mean, why did you
invite her over? You literally invited her over. I If you I Is
he pretending? He doesn't know that this would happen. If he
invites her over and ignores her, he knows exactly what will
happen. Her saying, "This is what you wanted." That's like maybe
the most coherent thing she said this whole night.
>> Dude, I can't breathe. Yeah, I'm off >> dude.
Dead ass. Like,
>> oh, now I'm off. So when the guy who sits on stream
and says, "Oh, I'm going to coke." Or you're going to see me
coked out. >> Yeah, I've got the clip. >> Call it
a home. >> Yeah, I said that. >> Okay, so you're
sitting here saying I'm on something, but yeah, you sit on stream
and say I'm like you're on something like mentally. >> Oh
yeah. >> Like I'm saying that because
>> like you got some [__] going on. Yeah, I
got some [__] going on because I'm not letting you
treat me like [__] anymore. Because I'm standing
up for myself instead of being THIS POOR VICTIM. EVERYONE WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT me being the victim. And now that I'm actually
trying not to be the victim, I'm the >> I'm being more
of the victim right now.
>> Okay, I don't care.
>> I She is kind of being a victim. She might actually
be a victim in some way. It's not in the way that you traditionally
say it. She might actually be like getting taken advantage of,
but she's not
she's she's uh she's making this public and like having this
crash out is bad. She shouldn't be doing this. She's not built
for this,
but she's making her money anyway she can. So, >> talk
about what you think.
>> I I >> Okay, Darius, do not talk to me. I don't
give a [__] about what you have to say. >> I'll
end my stream if I feel like >> No, NO, NO, NO. I like
you always.
I'm pretty sure he is living in a storage unit. >> Yeah,
I'm living in a storage unit. Even though he knows exactly where
I live, he just said it on
>> I'm not going to give people my address simply because
they think I or I have
>> when literally they've met my roommate. They've seen
where I live >> the past couple months. >> I don't
have to prove
what they think.
>> Great. Good. I'm tall. It's the end of the world. I'm
tall. Oh my god.
>> I'm tall.
I'm tall. Oh my god. It's the end of the world. I'm a tall girl.
Holy [__] They act like I'm the only >> It's
like the most predictable outcome in the world. >> Tall
woman in the world. Boo. [__] >> Are you okay,
dude? Like I'm not I got to get >> Oh, so your chat can
sit here and make fun of me for being TALL AND SIT HERE AND SAY
NO, NO, NO. Don't you just like >> No. Okay, I can respond.
>> But it's we're sitting here debating my I don't give
a I don't give a about what you say.
>> So just drop me out. You're not gonna see I'm gonna
allow your chat to gaslight me. >> I'm not lying to you.
>> Okay, buddy. I did I say you're lying? Did I say the
words you're lying to your chat? I said you're gaslighting. You're
>> I'm not gaslighting you. >> I think that I think
that our situation >> I don't give a [__] about
you. I don't give a [__] about what you say. I don't
give a [__] >> 30 years old having a 20-year
marriage divorce level crash out. Darius is literally older than
me, but nobody says anything about Darius. >> They do all
the time. >> Then Maj. >> Yeah, that's not fair.
Lots of people [__] on Darius. Okay, that's like
that's not true. That whole Darius Japan stream, that was some
of the most embarrassing [__] I've ever seen occur
in public and we talked all the in the world about him for that.
So, this is not true.
>> It's no
seem. Yeah. How fun. Awesome content. M crashing out. I can't
get uh away from her. Of course, >> I don't care. I don't
care. >> I don't care. >> If you care, I can I can
stop them from you. They do it to me. >> They could They
just do that to me. >> I don't care. >> I understand
you want.
>> I understand that. I heard. I'm sorry. >> Not
this dick thought. >> I'm being serious. I'm sorry. >> [__]
I don't want your apology. >> Aras could never do wrong.
Life is not >> as soon as like the uh as soon as the air
is sucked out of the room. I'm imagining it just goes like silent
like at some point you just realize you're saying the same things
over and over again and you just stop for once and not crash
out.
>> I just I just think I think personally we have different
content goals and >> I think I think No, I think I think
I think I think
>> I don't know why M does this to be honest with you.
I maybe
It's possible it's an act. I just don't think it is. And
I feel like she's literally never going to be happy doing this.
It just It's never going to work out, right? She's never going
to be like happy about this after the fact. It's just going to
end up like hurting more
>> No, I think we have different uh content. You would
like to do um getting drunk at the rooster. I would like to
do stuff like this. I thought it was pretty
>> Like you gave us >> because we have the We don't
have a job. What do you mean? It's [__] It was 10:00
p.m. at the time. So, oh, I'm sorry that I wanted to do sp something
spontaneous when you didn't want to provide a drinking date.
You didn't want to do anything. They were sitting on the couch
playing a [__] video game. >> Have you never
been tired or not?
>> Uh, you could say this, Ry. You could say it's autism.
But unfortunately, basically, everybody has this autism. All
it takes, everybody's done this like physically when they're
kids. If you're a guy, you've done the like play fighting thing
where one of you like actually hits too hard and then it's like
a real fight suddenly, right? It's that that's exactly what this
is. It's like on an emotional level though. It's it's just like
people
Darius says something or she says something to Darius and the
other person just goes off like they can't actually figure it
the out >> because I don't do we get paid to do nothing
ALL THE TIME. I'M so sorry that I wanted to go do something that
was actually interesting. I'm so sorry. It'll never happen. to
apologize
after you drop me off. >> Do not contact
just asked
>> cuz I'm
>> You're not the problem. >> I'm not saying you're
not saying you're the problem. >> I'm just like
you're not going to be super
I don't care. We do nothing. We get paid to do nothing. So, I'm
sorry that I actually wanted
for that. You're bad for that. >> Okay, then.
>> There's no problem. Darius, I'm asking
>> just please drop me off. Or if you would like to drop
me off in a gas station, I'll leave her down. >> Do not
speak to me. I have nothing to >> You want me to
set your collection on fire? >> I would rather just pay
the money to you. She pretends like for context
as soon as Darius says one word to defend >> It's inappropriate
to ask.
>> Uh let's just go to the bridge. This person wants the
content. Okay, that's what this person wants.
I hope this person doesn't get like attached.
That's my only fear. Okay. I feel like I feel like I just watched
this perpetual thing happen where one of these people who's with
who's trying to be with Darius is attached and the other one
crashes out and then and then or sorry that one crashes out.
The one who's like just new comes in and they think it's like
funny and then they don't realize that they're looking at the
ghost of Christmas future. Okay, this person is there. They're
the ghost of Christmas future. If you keep hanging around this
is going to be you >> to do something whenever you >> It's
not inappropriate. Do you want to drop me off please? >> Thank
you. But >> nothing's in her. >> Please don't drop
me off. >> Thank you. >> You are too pretty for her.
Darius, >> where's the nearest ice facility? >> Maybe
it's close.
>> No, you can't make any jokes about ice. I'm so bad.
Don't make any jokes about
>> Make jokes about ice. I can't say
>> Oh, what did I say? Don't speak to me to drop me off.
>> You're in a safe place. >> Oh my Oh my Oh, now
now you see what he's doing. night. >> Okay, after this
we go to
I like eventually they do drop her off. She gets out.
Wait, it's daytime? I thought it was night out. What the [__]
You're like
>> there's like there's more stuff after this. Check it
out. >> Oh, this is
Shut up. Shut up. >> It's cooler than >> Oh, no.
I don't give a [__] >> I don't care.
>> I don't care.
>> She is going to be more mad at you as soon as you drop
her off. Do you want me to take you back? I can take you. >> I
want you to drop me off at the nearest gas station.
>> Just dump her on the side of the road. >> Yes,
please. Please. I will. >> Darius, her clock is ticking.
The ball is in your court.
>> Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Dar, >> just do a roll
right now.
>> There's also a gas station right there. I'm going to
go to the gas station. >> Lay pipe already so she calms
down. >> I'm good.
So, I am thinking of Merc being in my
>> Spongebob TTS. I don't know. Is it the Spongebob? Dr.
Phil's good. Dr. Phil is very good. Okay. I don't think Spongebob's
king. I think Dr. Phil's king. The Thraw is underrated as well.
Exclamation thr. Okay, that Warcraft 3 voice, it's solid.
And those are my top three. I don't know. For the CX streams,
the Ice Boseidon voice could be funny, >> New town. She
could be a psychologist or >> Wait, no, let it drop you
off. I'm good. >> Always keep your eyes on the ball. Do
not let the ball go. >> Are you sure? Like >> Yeah,
I'm very Yes, I'm very good.
>> For the millionth time. >> We were going to go
to the bridge. Unlimited or premium.
>> Do you want to go to the bridge? >> Without the
week. >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> I think
we still going to the bridge
>> I have the address for it. [laughter]
>> Yeah, this dude. This girl is psychotic.
I I Although I do think that Murk would be in the same position.
Okay, let's just go stream the exact content she wanted to do
without her. Let's just go Let's go do that. She's stoned. Maybe
she's stoned. I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't know.
Let's That's
I thought they all didn't want to go out and do. Now she's like,
"Let's go to the bridge. Let's all go. Let's have fun." >> The
bridge. >> Yeah. [__] >> I mean, I'm
not
going to give the [__] at this point. >> We'll
see. Like we'll only get >> I knew I was so close to going
home, >> Wait, how far? >> So close. >> Wait,
that guy in the car is so Yeah, he was trying to go home and
Burke like convinced him, debated him into going and now she's
not even going. >> This reminds me of that one time called
Dill a [__] >> Will ran out of the car.
>> This basically city. >> You better stay in the
back of you, >> The airport [__] probably by
the
>> Happy prawns >> giving everyone